each year almost a million people from
around the world immigrate to the U.S in
search of a better future whether they
come for safety or educational
opportunities or higher paying jobs our
culture loves stories about people
achieving that shiny American dream of
financial prosperity get a good job save
for the future buy a house build wealth
but one thing that first generation
Americans find out pretty quickly is
that immigration can come with a bunch
of unexpected costs and that means the
path to the American dream may have at
least a couple of detours
[Music]
the first bump in the road to making it
it takes money just to be able to
emigrate there are fees for a green card
to establish your permanent residence or
you may have to pay separately for work
permits or background checks once you
qualify for permanent citizenship there
are application fees for that too
altogether the costs can come to over a
thousand dollars per person every time
you have to renew your paperwork and in
2023 many of these fees are set to
increase even double in some cases
paying these costs would be like adding
another car payment or student loan
payment to an already tight monthly
budget and since generally you have to
be a permanent resident for at least
five years before you can apply for
citizenship first gen Americans have to
be prepared to pay these fees for a long
time okay so you've carefully budgeted
so that you can pay for all that
paperwork you still have to pay for
regular life stuff too the rent or
mortgage Education costs and utility
bills we all deal with keeping all of
these things afloat can be hard enough
for any of us but first generation
Americans often have to work even harder
for one newly arrived immigrants are
more likely to be unthanked meaning they
don't have any kind of savings or
checking account at a bank or Credit
Union they may also have difficulty
qualifying for credit cards or loans if
they don't have a credit history or
social security number there are many
reasons first gen Americans may not have
a bank account a high minimum balance
requirements and ability to supply the
required forms of identification lack of
credit history or even language barriers
or lack of access to a brick and mortar
Bank location but being unbanked can
make people far more likely to use
predatory Financial Services like payday
lenders in order to cash paychecks or
pay bills just like we discussed in our
episode about why it's more expensive to
be poor unbanked individuals have to pay
a premium just to take care of the
normal costs of living and when money is
tight many first-generation Americans
don't have access to the same safety
nets as folks born in the U.S there's no
moving back in with mom or dad or
borrowing money from a family member but
non-citizens often can't access
government safety nets either even if
they qualify for programs like Medicaid
SNAP food assistance or supplemental
income many first generation Americans
are scared to use them that's because
the Department of Homeland Security has
a public charge rule where they can deny
immigration or citizenship applications
to people who have used public benefits
the rules for which specific benefit
programs disqualify people have changed
from Administration to Administration so
many folks play it safe and avoid these
safety nets altogether for for all these
reasons if you're a first generation
American it can feel like you're
entirely on your own to make ends meet
or that you have to work twice as hard
as other people just to keep up but all
this hard work still feels worth it to
many immigrants because of another
unique category of costs one of the main
reasons folks immigrate in the first
place is so they can financially support
family abroad people in the U.S send
almost 150 billion dollars of cash
payments also called remittances to
other countries each year that's triple
what the US government spends annually
on foreign aid the average migrant
worker is spending about 15 percent of
their paycheck on sending money back
home to the one in nine people globally
who are supported by remittances this
money often pays for housing and health
care for spouses and parents or
education for children or siblings which
makes remittance payments incredibly
important to the global economy but it's
not all sending money out American
immigrants contribute to the economy in
the U.S through increased productivity
tax revenue and consumer demand the
American Immigration Council estimates
that foreign foreign workers pay almost
half a trillion dollars in taxes and
have 1.3 trillion dollars of annual
spending power and first generators are
likely to create jobs too one in four
new businesses in the U.S is started by
an immigrant despite the extra
challenges they face first gen Americans
add value to the economy everywhere gosh
that's a lot with all these extra
Financial burdens is there any way to
lighten the load well if you're a first
generation American the first thing you
should know is that you don't have to
navigate the U.S financial system alone
many non-profit Aid organizations can
help you get access to a bank account
give you guidance on spotting Financial
scams and even help you apply for fee
waivers for all those annual permits and
paperwork second don't forget to budget
for your own savings first it can be
tempting to send as much money home as
you can as soon as possible but building
up a safety net for yourself will help
you to support family in the long term
it's like putting on your own oxygen
mask before helping others and finally
make sure to build a support network of
other friends neighbors or co-workers
who feel your first gen struggles
dealing with all of these unique
Financial issues can be isolating so
don't be embarrassed to ask your peers
how they're making it work even if
talking about money feels scary or
impolite everybody learns how to manage
their finances from other people the
best advice comes from those who have
been in your shoes before and that's our
two cents
thanks to our patrons for keeping two
cents financially healthy click the link
in the description to become a two cents
Patron
for more on the costs of being unbanked
check out our video why it's more
expensive to be poor
foreign